CBS News legal analyst Ricky Kleman is
with us for more on this Ricky good
morning morning so from a legal
standpoint as the president is flying
back home to the US what should he be
most worried about this morning he
should be most worried about the
Southern District of New York there is
no doubt in my mind about that what you
have in Michael Cohen is someone who was
telling the truth or not so what is a
prosecutor do a prosecutor who looks at
what he says and says how can I
corroborate this because we know that
Michael Cohen is a liar he admits that
he's a liar he has lied to Congress he
has pled guilty to fraudulent crimes
involving lying so does it mean he could
never trial the truth
of course not well in fact the special
counsel has said that they were able to
corroborate much of what Michael Cohen
shared with them without any doubt in
the special counsel's office and the
Southern District of New York know much
more already than the Oversight
Committee nevertheless by bringing in
the checks alone
those checks are highly collaborative
and provocative so what you do have is
the possibility of a conspiracy of four
people that is the president Michael
Cohen Alan Weissenberg keys to the
kingdom in his pocket and Donald Trump
jr.
explain the keys to the kingdom comment
about weiselberger he is the most
important following witness remember he
was immunized back with the Southern
District of New York before Michael
Cohen's plea of guilty
he is the person with the checkbook he
is the person who knows where the money
went
the reason is the keys to the kingdom is
he has the keys to the kingdom not only
on the hush money cover-up which really
is the potential of a federal crime of
conspiracy to violate the election laws
but he has the financials so they're
going to want the financial statements
that were discussed as to whether they
were inflated and deflated do we know if
there is fraud there are lots of
possible to the the power the
prosecutors have so one of the other
damaging disclosures yesterday from
Michael Kohn was that the President may
have known in advance about the
WikiLeaks disclosures from Robert or
from Julian Assange to Roger stone
is it possible that they could have
phone records recordings of that
particular conversation or to
corroborate with the president no I
doubt that they actually have a
recording but they could have phone
records and you always have the other
possibility of other witness Roger
stones under a gag order so you can't
respond Arjen wouldn't know that
yesterday on Twitter Thank You Ricky